[Music]
welcome to MLA I 1 2 3 1 a glimpse into
CBS Interactive's a IML group my name is
Andrew Schwartz and I'm a product
manager for video AI at Google cloud and
today it's my pleasure to introduce Adam
Leary and Rob Harrigan from CBS eyes
applied machine learning group and as
the and we're excited to have them walk
you through their GCP journey as a brief
introduction at cloudy AI our mission is
to help enterprises transform their
business with the power of AI we do this
by offering a set of AI building blocks
such as our pre trained models as well
as auto mel products so that you can add
human-like capabilities like sight
language and conversation to your
applications over the course of the last
year so it's been a pleasure and it's
been amazing experience working with CBS
I as they've started to use some of
these applications and apply them the
two of the most common media
entertainment challenges this starting
last year they had zero services built
on GCP yet with a really small team of
just 7.5 people they've been able to
build two great AI services that they
can then use to power and help transform
each of CBS eyes 38 different content
brands and with that I'd like to pass it
over to Adam Larry to continue this
story thanks Andrew
good morning everybody
would like to cover today I'm going to
try to pack a lot in a little bit of
background so I think it's really
important to understand the context from
which the team emerged to understand our
path to product development so a little
bit in the background into motivation
I'll give you a little bit better
understanding of where we sit as a group
within CBS Interactive and what we have
to work with in terms of data and the
motivation center on why we use the
Google cloud a I building blocks and
we'll move on to
building products on Google cloud and
review our main product components and
dive into a few of them and then we'll
go into a little bit of a functional
overview of the architecture of our
components as well as a brief look at
the content processing system that
integrates with the cloud AI
products and then Rob will go over our
hybrid recommender system in more detail
and then we'll wrap up with the business
impact of these product components and a
brief look at what we're doing next so
as I mentioned and as Andrew mentioned
we're a small team that was part of a
larger central engineering group within
CBS Interactive so that means we work
across all of our digital brands we
started from scratch on Google cloud
January 2018 with no systems to migrate
so it's sort of a wonderful feeling in
some ways the expectation is that we
demonstrate our value to the brand's we
meet their product KPIs for example and
compete with other vendors so outside
competitors that come into our brands
and say hey we offer the Sprint this
service so we were able to integrate
with surfaces like services for brands
like Cena and CBS all access so inspired
by the nautical theme of kubernetes we
embarked on our own voyage so this this
theme of kubernetes also inspired our
own product names so you'll sort of see
those show up as well so the first
question was really where to start it's
a classic question of course and you can
do so many things in this space you
really can sort of overwhelm yourself so
to go from zero to production we had to
consider our AI business model
essentially which is the following thing
so opportunity so what's the opportunity
so consumer expectations are very high
in terms of how they interact with video
and so the business benefit of building
recommendations is also very high so we
also saw a lot of growth potential and
deepening our own understanding of our
own content
our brands for the entire organization
and for marketing teams product teams
sales search ads you name it so we call
this approach content awareness and our
own competitive advantages the data the
content and our own ability to get to it
and also with enriching content
understanding and recommendations we
took that as our starting point and as I
mentioned the barrier for data and
content was much lower for us so we took
advantage of that so who are the
consumers so who needs this who needs
these things that were trying to build
out so one was internal teams first of
all starting with ourself so sort of
like a good chef you know you keep
tasting your food as you make it so
you'll see a little bit of this later
our consumer facing customers where our
brands essentially also integrated
marketing teams and our ad teams as well
so for example our marketing teams wanna
send you know relevant materials to the
right users to let them know about the
latest show on all access so we can help
them make that happen in terms of policy
and process for our business model if
you will we as a team really needed to
orient ourselves to Google cloud so a
lot of us you know had not worked on
Google cloud at that time so we were
learning new technology as we went we
also some of us were learning principles
of distributed computing even basic
DevOps we're still amateurs at DevOps
but we have to do it and getting our own
C ICD service out so we also need to
sort of reorient our partners the people
we work with internally to deploying
living features as a column that require
a level experimentation to be successful
so then how we build it so applied Xin
our name so we essentially start with
cloud AI building blocks and do transfer
learning and our own success criteria
were twofold one we're our own product
KPI
so when we deliver a service through
brand what are their kpi's we try to
match those and then our own model
benchmarks for our own services
internally so as I mentioned what's the
motivation well we have a lot of
wonderful content to work with so videos
articles images like an image galleries
podcasts and we have access to them from
our brands so in order to build a really
good recommendation service we needed to
enrich what we know about our own
content there's a little nod to our new
show The Twilight Zone so we have a
little sample of content here you know
to give you a flavour what we have
gaming tech news news entertainment a
lot of events get covered as well live
events so back to the how we build it so
with the cloud AI building blocks we
essentially said what we're going to do
is we're going to use their services to
get us going and then once we get going
we'll start to build our own in-house
solutions on top of it so this
essentially comes down back to you know
sort of a classical approach to transfer
learning so we viewed using Google Cloud
II I like video intelligence vision
natural language there's a type of
transfer learning where we're trying to
get achievable representations in the
model since time to learn is reduced for
us with a very small team and then it's
going to increase performance for all of
our downstream services because we don't
have to think on that piece because it
really didn't make it any sense for us
to start from scratch with some of those
models like Google Cloud a I handles so
we took it from there
so speaking of time the proof was in the
production for us so this is just a
sample of some of the things that we
delivered on those timelines
so also to give you a sense of where we
are right now so here's a glance of what
the world looks like so the values
aren't really is important for me but
it's really seeing what we're combining
across CBS Interactive and it's really
the fact that we have a living system
now in production and we're able to code
deploy manage and deliver with a group
of seven and a half people so let me
dive in a little bit to our product
components so as I said we started with
initial idea of content awareness so
roughly speaking we divide our world
into three product classes or components
so first is content awareness so this is
our service that interacts with the
cloud AI api's video intelligence vision
etc as well as data from our own content
management systems and other important
data api's the second area of product is
what we call video services so these are
built on top of the first service
content awareness so for an example
automated captioning for our video
on-demand processing live streaming as
well doing object detection on live
streams bounding box as entities as well
automated clips thumbnails and store
adjusting and we'll talk a little bit
and I'll show you a few little examples
if all goes well in the video piece and
then the third class of course is
recommendations and search which Rob
will talk more about so how do we how do
we architect for all these product
solutions especially starting from zero
and kind of going as you go and
implement all the cloud a I products so
what I have here for you is what I like
to call a functional infrastructure and
I call it functional because I really
mix architecture and services for the
purpose of showing you how we process
content so a lot of our other components
aren't represented here but I wanted to
make it easy to read so working from the
bottom up
is a way to look at this setup here so
let me explain a little bit about the
color schema so the blue layer are the
media icons as obviously are the pieces
of content that do not live in within
our team system the paint layers are on
kubernetes the green
excuse me the purple layer is our
storage layer the green layer on top of
Cloud endpoints of our ap is the grey
layer is a messaging cue and monitoring
and the dotted box of course represents
the AI Cloud AI services that we use and
I'm also showing that we make heavy use
of the service management API as well so
I'm gonna walk you through a really
quick example how this might work so an
editor might finalize a video for
encoding in our content management
system so trawler here on the bottom
will find that piece of content and say
hey this is new send that off to our
content workers to start the job of
interacting with the cloud ai services
and then bring back the information
around is it ready yet and also starting
to store off the results we also then
we'll use pub/sub to emit messages to
our other services to say hey this
little bit of information is not already
go do your thing and a little bit of an
infrastructure call out for kubernetes
is it really aligned with our design
principles of the immutability of
services and declarative configuration
for our system and allows us to grow and
scale quickly so let me dive a little
bit further into the content awareness
architecture where we're using video
intelligence so going from left to right
here what we do obviously is we're
topping into our various video feeds for
built by our end video tech teams so
we'll handle a couple of different
formats video on-demand and live stream
often in the form of HLS and then we
also will handle when our content
management system
have updates or D publish something so
that's our data ops bit as I call it and
then we'll track the operation via the
service management API it's very
important when you have longer video
content to really make heavy use of the
long-running operation to understand
when that's going process is going to be
complete so that systems aren't left
waiting and then what we'll do is we'll
we'll gather what has ever been what has
been called by the service so that might
include for video intelligence getting
this shot change information segment
level labels frame level information and
entities if needed whatever is needed so
what we do so in my where to start
section I mentioned customers so one way
we address this need is to sit to make
our work come alive is in a web app so
this is where we're eating our own dog
food so all the api's we've built we put
it all into our own web app so what
you're really seeing here is the output
of some of the services that I just
mentioned so we have the video on the
Aston Martin
Red Bull simulator racing simulator and
as it steps through the shot changes
I've been have been detected it updates
the top level shot entities that we've
also detected and then the right-hand
side there you see three little tiny
video clips those are the output of one
of our video services which I'll show
you a little bit more about in a minute
and you also see of course the output of
the speech transcription where we've
done a lot of extra post-processing to
make the captions actually look and feel
really nice
so let me go on to one of the video
services I mentioned so this one we call
splice so let's say we have a video
about a Mars helicopter which is pretty
compelling to me so what we do is we
treat all of our videos was essentially
a type of narrative discourse so they're
all some sort of story it doesn't matter
where it comes from and then we'll break
that down into its foreground
information and its background
information and foreground and
background has a lot to do with how a
narrative it goes forward and how we
understand narratives so let's say we
have this video clip here this is what
the whole thing looks like and WTF by
the way means who the future so don't
think I'm trying to fool anybody so you
get a sense here this is the clip okay
so now we'll help take a look at what
spice is looking at so Rob if you can
play that first one you can play the
splice too so what you have here on the
right hand side is the output of our
splice algorithm gives you the top three
candidates of what we would consider to
be the most engaging compromise video so
what we'll do is what we're charting for
you in our own web application is the
output also the scoring for information
gained on the foregrounding and back
rounding and other detail information
from the video itself and then this
these clips these cue points if you will
will get sent back into our video system
to be picked up and then used by the
brands so as you can see here there's
often a lot of action that gets captured
often a lot of gist information around
what the video is about and that's the
goal of an animated thumbnail thumbnail
essentially is to capture your interest
so now I'll turn it over to Rob to go
into a little more detail about our
hybrid recommender system thanks Adam
so I'm Rob Harrigan I'm a senior machine
learning engineer with the applied
machine learning group at CBS I and my
focus is on recommendations so I want to
dig into two of our services today and
those services are genrih which is our
generalized recommender and Admiral and
now he's obviously the leader of the
recommendations
he tells which recommendation to go
where so a little bit of motivation the
goal of this is we want baseline
recommendations for any brands that
we're ingesting and analyzing content
for so we have this great content
awareness built on these cloudy I api's
up API outputs and we want to be able to
generate some baseline content to
content recommendations and the fact
that this is a content content simpler
similarity recommender is a really it's
a decision that we made purposefully and
that has a lot of motivation one of
which is that our brands our content
generation sites and so they're used to
delivering content and often
personalization can add its own issues
with caching and delivery and we don't
want to introduce any of that problem
for a baseline recommender also our
recommendations should be content
agnostic we want to be able to take all
the different types of content images
image galleries reviews articles all
these different pieces of content and
recommend them for each other they're
all about some topics we can find which
ones are similar and recommend them and
so we really had three pillars that we
wanted to focus on when we build this
platform the first is flexibility like
the duck boat or as Adam might say the
shrim bogging and so like a duck boat we
need to be able to be on land and in
water we need to be able to handle lots
of rapidly changing business logic with
a small team we need to be configuration
driven and be able to select models
quickly and accurately based on whatever
the brands needs second we need to be
powerful like the Ferrari
new content has to be recommended
quickly and slowly we have news cycles
that are very fast think CBS News and
we've got content that has very slow
news cycles like an iPhone review on
CNET so this API will also go on the
front ends and so it needs to be fast
and scalable it needs to be performant
and we need to support combinatorics we
need to be able to combine different
sets of recommendations together at
dynamically at request time lastly it
needs to be reliable we need to also be
a 90 Civic right since this is going on
sites front ends directly we can't go
down and again we have amateur dev ops
we have a small team we need high
availability without a lot of DevOps so
we want a separation of powers between
recommendation creation and serving we
want those two to be separated so that
there's a little overlap so first
flexibility by flexibility
I mean deciding which recommendations to
choose or not choose based on customers
business rules and business logic
they're going to give us rules like
users with five page views today
shouldn't get trending right or everyone
who lives in Poland should get this
recommendation or not this
recommendation and we fully expect these
rules to be complicated and rapidly
changing and we need to support whatever
the business can tell us about a user a
piece of content any requests they make
to us we need to be able to make
decisions based on that and again as a
small team we need to be able to make
these easily in a configuration driven
environment so that we can iterate
rapidly and don't have any downtime so
we utilize gamal language and here's an
example over here under the duck boat so
you can see we've got three recommenders
and so the first recommender would only
be valid for users that the site or the
brand tells us has at least three page
views and is authenticated in the second
one only valid for users with at least
five pageviews notice they don't have to
be authenticated the third one is for
somebody who really loves that site but
the point is that these variables can be
anything that the brand can tell us and
pass into us at requests on the second
pillar is
power we need to be like the Ferrari and
this really refers to two different
goals which work in harmony the first is
that we need to combine models
dynamically at request time and the
second is the rapid ingestion of new
content we need speed in our time -
recommendation so besides just being
able to select models which is what I
talked about in flexibility we want to
be able to combine and backfill models
dynamically in a configuration driven
manner at request time support for
combining recommendations really
simplifies our back-end because it means
that we don't have to pre-compute
all possible combinations if a user is
interested in articles and video on one
of our brands say CNET we don't have to
compute an article and video
recommendation set we can combine the
article recommendations and video
recommendations and this helps with our
speed of ingest because there's less
things that we need to pre-compute
it also keeps our storage down and so
obviously speed of ingest is important
because time that we're generating
recommendations those pieces of content
are not being recommended if you think
about the lifecycle of a piece of
content on one of our brands like CBS
News it could be very short and if we're
taking hours to generate recommendations
we could completely miss the time where
that piece of content was relevant so we
have support for a number of combination
types all dynamically at request times -
the first is order so return this gen
reco model and then a fallback
some say trending or something the
second would be an inter leave so we're
gonna alternate recommendations or in
the case of more than two round-robin
the third would be score so we have the
model scores stored in there so if the
model scores are comparable we can
combine those by the actual similarity
score and lastly is weight so this would
be I want to take these this subset of
recommendations but maybe order them by
how popular they are at the time or
something right and so over here on the
right again we have an example so you
can see that the class this is a Redis
recommender and underneath in these args
we can see that we've got two data
sources coming from Redis so we've got a
general model which takes input of site
and content type and we've got a
fallback recommender and you can see
that one parameter sort of interleave
means that we're going to return
a gen reco and then a fall back and then
a gen reco and then a fall back but we
can change that one parameter to order
to return gen reco and then fall back or
score to order them by their similarity
scores the last pillar is reliability
reliability is crucial for any
production recommendation API our
challenge is that our team has limited
resources with only a few team members
and no dedicated dev ops staff and
machine learning iterates fastest and
works best in an environment where
experimentation and collaboration is
encouraged that often times does not
coalesce well with stability so our
engineers and our data scientists need
to feel free to experiment on back-end
systems not too free but pretty free and
these recommendation models they need to
be able to create new ones without fear
of breaking what's already working right
so this means that where we create our
recommendations in the backend and where
we serve them in the front end should be
distinctly different systems and you can
work on one and not the other and we can
update business logic on one and not the
other and so this is this is done we
should serve the best recommendations at
any given time okay we're going to
update recommendations as fast as we can
and we give out the best recommendations
that we know of at that time and Google
Cloud endpoints helps us a lot here
because it handles authentication
monitoring as well as giving us a
central place for API documentation
which you can see here on the right
that's our portal which is part of
Google Cloud endpoints and it takes your
open API spec and it gives some nice
swagger documentation so let's take a
look at the architecture and how this
enables or supports our three pillars so
reliability really starts with Admiral
all the way on the left you can see that
the only piece of our infrastructure
between our customer and Redis which is
where we store our recommendations is
Admiral it controls what models are
selected and what recommendations are
returned and it is the only choke point
for reliability our ingest process as
Adam has already showed you a little bit
starts with trawler all the way on the
right where we source data into the
content awareness system and then we
augmented with the cloud AI api's and
store it and then Jen reco is really
three cron jobs remember we're a mature
DevOps here and an auto scaling worker
service so I'm gonna go through these
steps in a logical order but it's
important to remember that in production
these are all happening simultaneously
so that we can get content in as fast as
possible but the first step up top there
is data collector and so data collector
sources data from our content awareness
system which is augmented with the
output of the cloud ai api's and it
stores it into gen reco and formats it
in a way that we can use it
gen reco submit is what we call the next
step and so if we tried to just compare
every piece of content that we get with
every other piece of content it would be
an intractable problem it would require
lots of resources and most of those
comparisons would be useless so this
first step is a filter to identify based
on some initial processing we identify
the content that's most likely to be
recommended for any given piece of
content and then we submit those as jobs
to our auto scaling workers those
workers then compute the actual
similarity metrics based on our models
and they can scale up own content
creation is high and scale down when
there's no content coming in the last
step is the most important and so what
we call gen reco and that's where we
actually create the recommendations so
we pull all the comparisons that have
been computed by the workers and we
generate the best recommendations that
we have at the time and again this is
all running in parallel at you know at
any given time we're just getting the
best recommendations that we have at
that time so how does this meet our
goals it's flexible because Admiral can
just serve JSON blobs we can change
business logic configuration easily in
Admiral it's powerful because we combine
recommendations in all these different
manners we can have interleaving score
order weight and all we have to do is
have models in Redis and we can combine
them dynamically we don't have to
compute every
possible combination that a customer
might be interested in because we have
these other sets that we can use to
build it and this means that in just
happens as fast as possible content is
constantly moving through this pipeline
and we're generating some
recommendations as fast as we can and
then we're continually updating those
recommendations to make sure they're the
best that we know of at that time
reliability if any of these cron jobs
goes down misses a run breaks nothing
happens not exactly nothing something
happens but it's not that big of a deal
we don't we don't update recommendations
for those five minutes we have this
buffer time as engineers to work on this
back-end system where it won't affect
any of our customers who are being
served recommendations and so this
low-pressure environment is really great
for our mo engineers to be able to
iterate rapidly and create new models so
you might be wondering boy that's a lot
of boxes does it actually work I'm happy
to say yes in multiple tests we've shown
an increase in customer engagement of 14
percent so now I'm going to hand it back
to Adam for the conclusions and future
directions thank you rob
so before I kind of go into our summary
in future directions I hope that you
starting to get a flavor of the types of
systems on Google cloud in general that
we started to use and some of the
decisions that we made along the way
which of course you know we're always
going to improve as well but what I
would like to we so we've sort of taken
you through our own story so to speak so
let's take a look a little bit at what
some of the business impact we're seeing
as we progress as a team and what are
some of our next areas of work so what
has really emerged from our initial work
is a few things so visibility into our
own content across brands so what I mean
by that you know is the enrichment of
the information that we get back from
cloud a I services on our content
and this is also spurred some new areas
for us like we're now able to search
across videos images all those entity
objects in turn this this visibility is
beginning to address sort of a pent-up
demand as I call it from our marketing
teams to be able to rely on some of
these internal solutions and also what's
really important to me is that we're now
a consideration for wind features are
being developed for our content
management systems and our video tech
and our video players so our fellow
teams have been very supportive in our
journey and are very strong advocates of
our progress as well so at the onset I
mentioned we are tasked with competing
head-to-head with a lot of outside
companies that come to CBS Interactive
and say hey let's do a POC so you might
be demoing their work with their own
brands so this is one of the motivators
for us to have our own web application
as well to sort of do our own sales
pitch to these brands as well and then
say hey we're happy to go into a test
with our services and their services and
we have done that so we're also able now
to provide some strategic options for
the company and you know in many cases
we can do it much cheaper and so finally
we're here to help CBS Interactive as a
whole sort of embrace the possibilities
of using ml and AI because it really is
as you know if you work in the area it's
it requires a bit of a mind shift and so
we also are aiming to produce some
toolkits and packages that can be reused
by our other data science teams and bi
teams across the company so that they
reduce their amount of initial work so
what are we gonna look at next
where are we doing now and what are we
working on so some of the things that
we're working on now and this year are
following so I mentioned earlier in the
talk video live-streaming enhancements
so we are working on providing some
interesting features on top of live
streams so coming soon second is
we're in the process of implementing
cube flow for our machine learning
pipeline management we've really reached
the maturity point where we need to sort
of get ops our pipelines and allow them
to be reusable by our ml engineering
team and even possibly other data
science teams another area that's really
important for us is that we're exploring
is ganz so generative adversarial
networks for recommendation simulation
so since we're sitting as a central team
among all these brands we're often ready
to go and we're waiting for the brand to
do their implementation of our API so
instead of just having that be wasted
downtime what we'll do is we'll create
some Gans that simulate user behaviors
have it hit our own api's and continue
to tune the models we're also working on
stacked embeddings within hybrid
recommender that Rob went over so one of
the one of the great ways that it was
designed is it allows us to add many
different what we call flows and so each
of those flows can be a different
stacked embedding and we're starting to
do our own benchmarking against other
systems so that we can continue to
monitor its behavior and meeting our own
expectations as well as the product
expectations
and then the another area that we are
working with is using auto ml video and
auto ml entity extraction for our
missing some of the organizational
knowledge and let me explain what I mean
by that so for auto ml video we'll use
that for a secondary customization so as
you as we get information in from the
initial cloud a I like video
intelligence labels at the frame level
and get the web entities will often need
to tune them for certain brand use cases
because it's a particular person or
brand name might be very rare and hasn't
really been seen so it gets mislabeled
so we'll use a auto ml video to sort of
do a secondary post-processing update
and then we'll inject that back into our
system to keep improving it and with the
entity extraction and that's all
going to have a similar function within
our systems
[Music]